this movie i think was supposed to come
out this time this year
but now we have a teaser trailer instead
teaser trailer number two
for halloween kills excited check this
out
i do want to thank everyone who's been
commenting on uh my midsummer movie
reactions got so many comments there
thank you guys so much for watching if
you haven't seen it go check it out
anywho
let's see this short little teaser right
now
next halloween
when the sun sets and someone is alone
see his mask yeah
[Music]
oh no oh cool
wow two super short teaser trailers is
all we've got in this year
for this movie that looked great though
yeah happy blem fest there's actually a
lot to kind of gather from but we'll
keep it really short but from the last
user trailer where you hear like the
fire trucks the ambulances are going to
go grab michael myers here you have
jamie lee curtis and michael
inside of a hospital you see out there
the ambulance
and then people are like protesting you
got the guy with the bat looking like
hey we're gonna take out michael myers
it looks like the town is revolting
against him and i imagine when he
escapes i don't know how the mask
lands on the ground but somehow he's
gonna break out of that hospital
it's funny how this halloween reboot was
kind of sort of h2o and this is kind of
feeling like halloween too rob zombies
but a better version yes
you know every second installment of a
new halloween
iteration has to go to the hospital
now this it almost looks like this could
be cool because maybe they're gonna yeah
do some play where it's like michael is
the one
in the hospital and he's gonna find some
horrific way to break out i mean that
could also be kind of
campy i guess the tone just coming off
this is really cool that one
gash with the knife yeah is super
visceral
it seems like the riots within halloween
the riots that are going to occur are
probably going to be away from how he
can actually
escape from the situation and it looks
like it's still taking place on that
same exact halloween
i love the idea that haddenfield is
really getting involved the townspeople
of hattonfield are getting involved all
right this looks really cool man what'd
you guys think of this teaser i like it
more than the other ones so
hell yeah man from michael b back he's
got a gash on his mask
let's do this happy halloween i hope you
guys are able to do something this year
i kind of feel like the mood and energy
and vibe because of everything going on
in the world right now but it hasn't
been as exciting to celebrate halloween
but
try to do something with a few loved
ones if you can don't go to banana
sandwich all right
anywho subscribe click that notification
bell catch you guys soon hit that like
button